James André que l'on retrouve en direct
bonjour James vous le disiez dans le
reportage la plupart des civils ont fui
darkmouth mais il reste bien sûr encore
des milliers d'habitants sur place
comment s'en sortent-ils
voilà effectivement pour les habitants
qui sont sur place la situation est
effectivement extrêmement dure on l'a
dit pas d'eau pas d'électricité on voit
les gens finalement comme des ombres qui
sont à l'intérieur de cette ville qui
est constamment sous le feu de
l'artillerie c'est un bruit roulant
permanent et ce qui est absolument
surprenant c'est de voir ces personnes
ces habitants de la ville circulaient
sans même réagir vous avez d'énormes
explosions et les gens ne réagissent
absolument plus il y a un militaire qui
nous disait c'est étonnant à voir il
venait d'arriver lui à barthout on l'a
rencontré ce matin il nous disait j'ai
rarement vu ça ailleurs ça fait des mois
qui sont sous le feu et ils ne
réagissent même plus alors on a parlé
une dame les raisons pour lesquelles ces
gens-là reste sont multiples elles nous
disaient elle qu'elle n'avait pas
confiance qu'elle avait nulle part où
aller et qu'elle ne faisait pas
confiance à la qualité des endroits où
elle pourrait être hébergée à ni pro si
elle faisait le choix de faire une
évacuation du même type que celle que
vous avez vu dans le reportage d'autres
tout simplement sont trop vieux ou Truma
trop malades pour bouger des personnes
qui sont octogénaires qui vous disent
bah écoutez je j'ai bâti toute ma ville
ici je vais pas recommencer maintenant
je reste on verra bien depuis dans une
ville comme barmut il faut bien le dire
il y a aussi les prorus comme le père de
cette jeune fille Angelina a des gens
qui sont on va dire sur le fil qui se
disent ben écoutez pourquoi pas si
jamais les Russes prennent la ville et
bien moi je fais le choix de rester il y
en a beaucoup et c'est vrai que c'est
une ville qui est dans l'est du pays
près du Dombas une ville qui avant 2014
était massivement prorus les gens
beaucoup changé d'avis à l'image
d'Angelina après l'invasion russe des
territoires de Laurent ce qui est de
denette mais il y a aussi cette
composante prorus maintenant il faut
bien réaliser que sur les 70 000
habitants que comptait la ville et n'en
reste plus que deux à 5000
James vous me disait que vous êtes
retourné à darkmouth ce matin est-ce que
vous pouvez nous décrire la situation en
ville ce jeudi
bien écoutez ce jeudi ce qui est
étonnant parce qu'on était là
effectivement on l'a vraiment entendu on
était juste à la limite de l'Ouest et de
l'Est de la ville le long de la rivière
et on entendait très clairement des
combats à l'arme légère de rue qui
prenaient place dans la partie Est de
barmut c'est beaucoup trop dangereux
pour s'y rendre pour faire du reportage
d'ailleurs c'est interdit on ne peut y
aller qu'est-ce qu'on fait par les
militaires ils sont très occupés en ce
moment et il y a toujours ce duel
d'artillerie qui prend place alors en
revanche on a pu parler un militaire qui
nous a expliqué qu'effectivement la
situation avait été était d'ailleurs
toujours très tendu mais avait été très
tendu ces quelques derniers jours en
raison d'une percée des Russes qui ont
réussi à rentrer dans l'est de la ville
alors plus les faubourgs mais bien la
ville elle-même qu'il y avait une
contre-offensive ukrainienne en cours et
que grâce à cette contre-offensive alors
au moment où on se trouvait là c'est à
dire il y a à peine deux heures et bien
les
Ukrainiens avaient réussi à repousser
les Russes qui selon cette cette source
militaire nous disait qu'il ne
contrôlait plus que environ 500 mètres
une bande de 500 mètres
reste de cette ville de Dark mood mais
ce qu'on a vu également c'est que les
forces ukrainiennes sont en train de se
barricader de s'enterrer dans la ville
ils sont en train de creuser des
tranchées avec un objectif très clair
tenir backmouth coûte que coûte merci
pour ces infos essentielles sur la
bataille de Dark mode qui se poursuit
merci James André
les africains vont